Now that we have some background on why GPUs look the way they do,
we'll now discuss what a GPU looks like from the point of view of a software developer.
One of the themes of this class is the importance of programming in parallel.
This is a crucial skill, not just for GPUs, but also for CPUs even.
If you buy an 8 core Intel Ivy Bridge processor, we see that it has 8 cores.
Each core has 8-wide AVX vector operations.
Each core supports two simultaneously running threads.
Multiply those together and you get 128-way parallelism.
On this processor, if you run a completely serial, C program with no parallelism at all,
you're going to use less than 1% of the capabilities of this machine.
There's no doubt that parallel programming is harder than serial programming, no matter what your target.
But I hope by the end of the class, we'll convince you
that this additional complexity is worthwhile for the potential performance gains.
And throughout the course of the class,
we'll try to lay out the benefits and the limitations of this programming model.
One of the really exciting things about GPU computing is that it moves quickly,
and some of today's limitations may disappear in the next generation of GPUs.